news and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
this election is going to be a
referendum on senator masto
tonight on politics now recapping
primary night the showdown for nevada's
senate seat how adam laxalt won the
republican primary and look ahead to
november
the choice is clear i have the
experience and leadership nevadans can
trust
joe lombardo wins the republican
gubernatorial primary we preview his new
race against governor sisilak
do you want to take with the grain of
sonic what effect his endorsements
actually have
conservative versus moderate how
different edges of the republican party
fared on election night and the impact
of former president trump's endorsements
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler the
final mail-in ballots are being counted
but nevada's primary election is in the
books so let's take a look at the
winners and some of the match-ups for
november we're going to start with the
senate race former attorney general adam
laxalt beat sam brown pretty handily for
the republican nomination as you see on
your screen there he now faces senator
senator catherine cortez masto in the
general election in november laxalt as
you'll remember was endorsed by former
president trump here's his victory
speech
i would like to thank president donald
trump for not only believing in me
but for believing in nevada
and leading an america first movement a
movement that is alive and well today
here in nevada this election is going to
be a referendum on senator masto
and all of these elites who look down on
us
elections have consequences they say
and well
so do these liberal policies that are
driving nevada and our nation into the
ditch
senator cortez masto didn't give a
speech she won her primary though in a
statement she called laxalt a corrupt
a.g who led trump's efforts to overturn
the 2020 election on top of that she
writes he opposes a woman's right to
choose
the 8 news now i-teams david charn is
here to help us dig into some of these
races david let's talk about this senate
race and laxalt beating sam brown the
main challenger how did he do it yeah so
if you look at the races uh here the
numbers here and these are the the
latest numbers that have just updated
here you can see that he won by more
than 20 points against sam brown of
course an army veteran adam laxalt
former attorney general look at all this
red here though because this is the
county by county level that we can break
down for you
out of the majority of the counties in
our state here adam laxalt won every
single one and he really wanted here in
clark county above his average there
beating sam brown by 27 points almost
2-1 there up in washoe county where adam
laxalt lives 13 points also doing strong
there the only county where sam brown
did a little better and he barely eked
it out there by just about 60 votes was
in douglas county just outside of carson
city so you really see here voters
clearly sending a message in this race
that adam laxalt was their choice of
course he did have that endorsement from
former president trump john it's just
we'll have to see what happens in
november now of course going against
senator cortez masto a very different
race indeed let's talk about the other
huge race as well from primary from
primary night
that was the republican nomination for
governor clark county sheriff joe
lombardo won by a pretty sizable margin
beating joey gilbert an attorney from
northern nevada by about 20 points
former senator dean heller came in third
gilbert immediately started claiming
there was election fraud we'll have more
on that though in just a second lombardo
faces now democratic governor steve
sisolak in november here's what lombardo
said after the victory
the choice is clear i have the
experience and leadership nevadans can
trust
as your next governor i will guarantee
that my administration will eliminate
corruption from the governor's office
such as the covet testing scandal
and fix state agencies that have
forgotten who they work for
allow me to appeal to you the voters of
nevada we may not agree on every issue
but know that i will work hard to make
you proud to be in nevada
in a statement governor sysolak said
quote everything is at stake this year
and i'm running against a candidate who
wants to tear away our progress while
flouting his official responsibilities
on the campaign trail joe lombardo the
governor continues failed to put
nevadan's safety first proving to be yet
another politician with no vision just
looking for a promotion the governor and
the sheriff go back a long way of course
when uh governor siselek was on the
clark county commission david's here
again we're going to talk more about
these races let's talk about this race
for governor the republican primary and
we mentioned joey gilbert asking for a
recount what happens if that actually
takes place yeah well you see he's
behind 11 points here
there are no automatic recounts here
nevada we saw we talked a lot about this
in november 2020 right so it is up to
the candidate and gilbert would have to
request a recount within three business
days of when the election is actually
certified statewide that is the
canvassing and that's in a couple days
so he would have to pay for it as well
and sampling would have to be done
within 10 days but it is worth noting
that he lost as you see here by 11
points and the chances of eking out a
win with that with that big of a
difference here i mean it's 22 000 votes
here is a slim to none so let's take a
look at how lombardo won this race so
here are our five major candidates who
were standing right here for the debate
just a couple weeks ago you see here joe
lombardo winning with 38 not a not a
majority here but 38 percent of the vote
all the way down to guinor here with
four percent but if we look at this from
a county by county look this is going to
break down in terms of the top two
candidates you see here the darker the
red again the better our top candidate
is doing so that is joe lombardo his
home county here of clark county nearly
50 000
uh two to one here to joey gilbert the
pinkish you hear you see some of these
other candidates so joey gilbert doing
better up in some of our rural counties
even dean heller coming in second in
some of these john lee comes in second
here in lincoln county though it's about
300 200 votes joel gilbert though
focusing up here on washoe that's where
he's live attorney a former boxer up in
reno you see here didn't win his home
county that's why he's thinking you know
all these folks say they loved me what
happened joe lombardo eking out the wind
there just by a couple hundred votes but
you see here overall pretty strong night
for uh sheriff lombardo and he does seem
adamant joey gilbert does that he wants
he claims that there's fraud he's pretty
serious about that so we'll see how that
goes forward and whether how sheriff
lombardo does getting his story to the
rest of the state also let's talk about
the congressional races uh we talked
david
the state legislature changed the lines
for the congressional districts here in
nevada so that certainly changes how
things play out here this is a look at
the third congressional district here
you can see april becker with the win
yeah so april becker winning here we saw
a lot of ads for her pumping gas so you
remember that ad talking about gas
prices she will go up against democratic
congresswoman suzy lee the third
district now is pretty much the western
and southern parts of clark county now
so we're talking a little more richer
less diverse that when the redistricting
was done they made the first district a
little more diverse
trying to make it a little more for a
democratic stronghold looking at the 4th
congressional district this is for
congressman stephen horsford's seat we
saw assemblywoman annie black lose to
sam peters a little bit of a surprise
here as we didn't hear much from sam
peters heading up to this race but he
won by about 3 000 votes there of course
this taken up a majority of the southern
part of our state and of course dina
titus in cd1
she is the incumbent in that race we'll
see what happens with her heading on
into the into the general election david
appreciate it now i also spoke with unlv
associate professor of political science
dan lee about all these primary races
and what stood out here's what he had to
say
what was your take away from that very
uh contentious and and sort of
money-filled race
right so i guess like from last night
there really weren't any surprises right
people that we thought were the front
runners ended up winning the races so
yeah lombardo winning the the
gubernatorial primary and then looking
at the senate lack cell winning that
ultimately winning that primary um
and in both cases those are trump
endorses at that one as well um so it
kind of just fits what we expect in that
that they would end up winning the
nominations
does it and i guess we kind of discussed
this leading up to primary knight but
it's interesting yes okay the trump
endorsement means one thing but
every candidate is was claiming to be
sort of the former trump guy or woman in
certain circumstances
i guess this shows it really matters
what he puts his stamp of approval on
the former president
yeah so you do want to take with a grain
of salt like what effect his
endorsements actually have
um so for instance you know in the case
of lombardo he was already the front
runner before he got the endorsement
right in a lot of ways yeah he wasn't
the most trumpian candidate like he was
getting attacked from his opponents all
in all from the right attacking him on
immigration on election integrity um on
gun control
so that's the case where you know
actually for both the senate and
gubernatorial races i don't think that
trump's endorsements were was they were
pivotal for those candidates to win
looking at the senate race uh adam lacks
all former ag wins uh that primary
you know the brown campaign seemed to
think they were making inroads leading
up to the primary obviously ultimately
didn't seem to to be successful um
what stood out to you if anything about
the turnout and the ultimate totals that
we've gotten on that primary race
you know that reflects what was going on
in the campaign
brown was building up support grassroots
support kind of culminating with the
endorsement from the nevada republican
party right so you see that he had you
know somewhat respectable showing but
again laxalt had too big of an advantage
to start with right because he's been
especially in the forefront um you know
as a big proponent of the election fraud
narrative right because he was trump's
co-chair uh for his campaign in nevada
in 2020 so we saw him in the news going
around telling stories about election
fraud that was going on he's been really
pushing that over the past few years so
he's been he's a well-known commodity
former attorney general in the state
it's a one-owned commodity and that's
that was too much for uh brown to
overcome let's uh let's move also to the
congressional races uh obviously they're
all held by democrats well that's kind
of the way it is for pretty much any of
the major uh
positions here in the state anything
stand up to you about the congressional
races uh some of them are pretty
hardcore uh blue seats and will likely
stay that way in the general uh but
there's some that are certainly up in
the up for grabs
yes
right so after redistricting pretty much
all of the democratic seats are up for
grabs right so uh i'm gonna die amadeus
district right but you look at titus's
district the first congressional
district that was a strong uh strong
democratic district but after
redistricting allocating some democratic
voters to
um the third and fourth districts
especially to the third and that now
makes the first district competitive for
the first time uh you know in in a long
while right so that attracted a lot of
uh candidates into the republican
primary so there that was one of the
primaries i was you know that was
somewhat up in the air we didn't really
know who was going to come out and that
promise i was interested in seeing how
that would play out uh ended up peterson
winning that primary which is a little
bit of a surprise because i think a lot
of people have their eyes on serrano um
to be a favorite coming out of that that
district um but either way like whoever
was going to win that primary the
republican primaries is going to get
titus you know her toughest um shot at
reelection uh since she's been in
congress so uh so really you know the
first um third and fourth districts
all like slightly leaning democratic
right but in an election year that
favors republicans that puts all of
those districts in play
we have a full list of all the primary
results at 8newsnow.com and we'll talk
more about the results later on here on
politics now so yes we're going to talk
more about the primary coming up here on
the program including from the da's
office to the school board who could be
in for a tough race moving forward and
who's settling into a new job
also rising interest rates how the
federal government hopes to slow
inflation with me
[Music]
welcome back to politics now
let's talk more about this week's
primary a closer look at the clark
county races district attorney steve
wolfson easily won his race for
re-election beating ozzie fumo in the
democratic primary now wolfson will face
republican challenger and defense
attorney tim treffinger in the general
election
the rest of these races are nonpartisan
so if someone gets more than 50 percent
they do win it otherwise the two top
vote getters each will face each other
in november so let's start with kevin
mcmahill easily winning the sheriff's
race here in clark county over tom
roberts former assemblyman he will now
replace joe lombardo in january and here
is what he said after his win
my message has been one of positivity my
message has been one of support my
message has been one of keeping the
crime low in this community and i know
how to do that i was the undersheriff
for six years i did 30 years in law
enforcement and i chose to come back and
put myself through that because i care
about this community
three incumbents are up for re-election
to the clark county school board
chairwoman rather of the board irene
cepeda will face stephen conger in
november incumbent trustee danielle ford
finished in second place behind former
assemblywoman irene bustamante adams for
district f so now they will face each
other in november because as david
mentioned neither of them got to that 50
percent threshold linda cavazos also
going to run off with greg wyman this is
for district g she is the only one of
the three who finished with the most
votes in their race to hold on to their
position yeah this has been a
controversial school board to say the
least it has gotten
we've seen the fights in these meetings
and on social media as well that's right
ford in fact trustee ford in particular
has been at the center of a lot of the
disputes online and at the board
meetings all three incumbent trustees
first voted to fire superintendent dr
jesus jara last year uh chairwoman
sipada switched her vote got dr jarrah
his job back it's very interesting to
see what's going to happen with the
school board moving forward depending on
what happens with the district and the
superintendent's office because
you as you know trustee ford in
particular wants him out of his job
right out and then he was in and now
we're seeing what happens and then it
could be even new people coming in and
coming into the general expect a lot
more money to go into those races to try
and shape where ccsd goes from and a lot
probably more tweets against each other
that we'll have to watch for
henderson is having a new mayor current
city councilwoman michelle romero
winning that race outright she used to
work at city hall down there north las
vegas mayoral race that's going to run
off as well city councilwoman pamela
goins-brown will take on state senator
pat spearman the winner will be north
las vegas first black mayor whoever wins
that race
in other big national news this week the
fed raised interest rates it was the
steepest increase in 30 years alex limon
explains how regulators hope this will
cut inflation
the price of oil globally is about 120
dollars a barrel and the last time it
was that price globally we were paying
4.25 cents at the pump but right now
americans are paying an average of
dollars a gallon bharat rama morty with
the national economic council says
that's because oil refineries are making
historically high profit margins senator
chris van hollen says that's a problem
my view
they are engaged in war profiteering and
they're not using the excess profits
to reinvest in production
they're using them for stock buybacks in
a letter calling on oil refineries to
produce more gasoline and diesel
president biden says he's prepared to
use emergency authority to force an
increase in output why would somebody
build a refinery or operate one at this
point and that's the challenge with the
refinery capacity republicans say
democrats push to shift the country to
clean energy is behind the high oil
prices and it's been fueled in large
part by democrats huge mistakes in
another effort to combat rising prices
the federal reserve announced a
three-quarter percent interest rate hike
that's the largest increase since 1994
and chairman jerome powell said more
interest rate hikes are expected we're
strongly committed to bringing inflation
back down
and we're moving expeditiously to do so
and that was alex limon reporting next
year on politics now demanding answers
nevada's senators call for an
investigation after the eight news now
i-teams report on a man's death at a
local va clinic
news now
you're watching politics now
a report by our eight news now i-team
spurs calls for a federal investigation
the i-team shed light on the lack of
prompt medical care for an elderly
veteran now two two u.s senators are
demanding answers the i-team's vanessa
murphy brings us a follow-up to her
exclusive story we do want to warn you
though some of the video is disturbing
how critical is this situation
he's dying u.s senators jackie rosen and
catherine
masto are demanding answers after our
report which first aired on may 23rd
this video leaked to the 8 news now
i-team shows an 88-year-old marine corps
veteran collapse inside a v-a medical
clinic in las vegas on june 7 of 2021 we
showed the video to a physician who runs
his own medical office and an attorney
with experience in medical malpractice
both pointed to a lack of urgency in
caring for the veteran tick tock it's
seeming like a long time already the
veteran was later taken to sunrise
hospital and pronounced dead in their
letter to the office of the inspector
general in washington d.c senators rosen
and cortez masto write we cannot allow a
tragedy like this to happen again they
also point to the time frames
demonstrated in our report two minutes
for a nurse to arrive and nearly five
minutes to begin cpr which dr scott
glickman called incomplete because the
staff didn't deliver breaths to the
veteran when we interviewed the head of
the v.a health care system in southern
nevada on april 14 we did not reveal we
had the leaked video do you think care
was delayed hands-on care to this
patient
so without getting into the details of
that patient i i would have to say no
i'd say we we responded accordingly that
you would see in any other
health care clinic of that nature after
the v.a learned we had the video a
spokesman sent a lengthy statement
admitting mistakes were made now both
u.s senators say the incident warrants
closer review from an independent entity
it's sad it's it's emotional that
you know somebody you're in a facility
where
you think that you're going to get
medical attention and you think you know
people are going to run to your rescue
and that's just not happening here
vanessa murphy live local now
the veterans family was told he died of
a heart attack they did not know about
the video you just saw until the i-team
contacted them an autopsy was not done
so we don't know if the delay in care
may have contributed to the veteran's
death you can find the original full
story at 8 news now
vegas area hyundai dealer
[Music]
this week in what to watch tomorrow is
juneteenth and there are several
celebrations this weekend across
southern nevada the city of las vegas
has hosted one today and tomorrow one is
being held at the art house lounge
juneteenth commemorates when slaves in
texas learned they were freed after the
civil war
also if there was an issue with your
primary ballot monday five o'clock that
is the deadline to get your signature
squared away this is a process known as
curing election officials will notify
you using the contact info in your voter
registration we have information on
where you can check your mail if your
ballot was counted
all at eightnewsnow.com now mail-in
ballots were allowed through friday so
now clark county the secretary of
state's office
both need to certify the election that's
known as canvassing we'll keep an eye on
that process as it moves forward as well
and we head towards the general election
that's it for politics now we're back
with you next week take care
[Music]